well it seems like about a decade ago
but it was only one calendar year from
today that the creepy porn lawyer was
all over television MSNBC and CNN and
they were telling us that he was
presidential material in case you've
forgotten here it is this president all
but acknowledged Vladimir Putin as the
President of the United States it's
ridiculous Chris as to why the president
would not want to get to the bottom of
the Russian collusion situation unless
he knows he's guilty mr. president for
you to live as a Manchurian Candidate in
why am I on CNN so much and why are you
giving him so much airtime well guess
what this is why we will never be part
of any effort to snow the American
people period well because karma is
absolutely real things promptly went
south for the creepy porn lawyer he's
now facing years in prison for how much
time do you have extortion theft tax
evasion lots of other things but he's a
sporty character he's not ready to give
up just yet today the creepy porn lawyer
pleaded not guilty to embezzlement
charges what's next for him
well author and columnist mark Stein has
been following this case as carefully as
a layman can and he joins us to his
assessment so mark is there a hope that
Cpl stays out of the big house not
really because the federal justice
system wins 99 percent of its cases 97
percent of them without ever taking them
to trial that is a rate of success that
Kim jong-un would envy so he is up
against some pretty stiff odds and I
love all this stuff you know I believe
in the presumption of innocence I do too
I do term with him on that but in the
end the reality of the federal justice
system both for both for this guy and
for the actress the trace was talking
about is that at some point you're
looking at 475 years in jail if you go
to trial so you tend to cut a plea and
the heroic moment here I'll be
interested to see if that
survives all the way to the courthouse
yeah I mean I don't want to prejudge the
situation and I'm not you know a juror
here I'm not even a licensed attorney
but all I know is that when he sat in
this studio this fall
our stage manager is a pretty sturdy
character was rattled to be in his press
so creepy was his presence I don't think
that's that's not going to help him in
court no no it won't and and the reality
is is that if it weren't for this
arraignment he'd have been at that White
House Correspondents Dinner and he'd
have been fated by those guys have said
he's speaking truth to power and they'd
have done all that flim-flam with him
and the fact is he's just a rotten
sleazy lawyer who comb engels his
clients accounts which in California is
about the one thing I mean the
California ethics code is the shortest
ethics code on the planet for California
Bar Association but that's about the one
thing you can still be nailed on and it
turns out he's not a heroic presidential
speaking truth to power guy he's just a
flim-flam shyster who steals from his
clients and and CNN couldn't he if it
weren't for this he would have been
there this weekend with Jeff Stoker's
Marianne died sipping Prosecco so I have
to ask you about this story we talked
about this last week but it just it had
your name all over it so last week
Filipino president Rodrigo Duterte vowed
to wage war on Canada if they didn't
stop dumping garbage into the
Philippines we will pretend to be
impartial in this fight we explained
last week if it's war the Philippines
has our full support I was shocked that
he would send his garbage to the
Philippines is struggling third-world
country needs more Canadian garbage I
mean it just seems the problem so
insensitive and that seemed like I don't
know it seemed like a form of of
colonialism garbage Chloe I don't think
it since I don't think it's a question
of insensitivity you know Tucker our
Prime Minister is very very sensitive
he'll bottles to Manila it just seems
like
pretty much to me I'm just throwing that
out there so it looks like the threats
from Duterte worked canada's ambassador
has said his country is scrambling to
bring back through those hair gel
bottles yeah we've already indicated
that we are prepared so this is an issue
that both governments have to work on
and solve together so that's all I'm
gonna say at this point yes but the
timeline of the government for you think
about this weird working as quickly as
we can
no timeline we're working as quickly as
we can so Canada's got back down by the
Philippines oh no this this this is this
is terrible Tucker these are used adult
diapers that Canada when we go to war we
take it seriously this is Canada shock
and awe leaving used adult diapers on
the dock in Manila and you were wrong to
blame Justin Trudeau for this these are
adult diapers and he's still on child
size so if you continue to provoke us
Tucker with all your sabre-rattling to
Canada we've read that poem at the
bottom of the Statue of Liberty about
the the wretched refuse of your teeming
Shore this is the most amount of refuse
on the most teeming Shore in history and
we're going to drop it off in the harbor
in New York if you don't back off with
your saber rattling to Canada
we'd have to be true to pillow fight if
that happened but I do you think as a
Canadian does this damage the national
pride that most Canadians feel deep
inside well I think it is actually a
beautiful thing because this is
recycling in action you know before we
just used to toss the adult well I
personally give my adult diapers to the
Clinton Foundation because that way they
are tax deductible but before we just
used to toss before we just used to toss
them in the landfill and now we say oh
well we need to save the planet
so let's ship them all the way to the
Philippines and leave them sitting on
the dock in the Philippines for six
years it's very easy and you know why
it's for the climate and I think you say
your mana on behalf one diaper
time toned I print whatever however many
diapers it takes for the climate will be
there you and me mark great to see you
thank you for that